how many times I've thought about
putting a camera in the studio that is
constantly on and constantly streaming
what I'm doing in the studio to the
Internet
because if that was true I promise you I
would not masturbate I promise you I
would not eat refined sugar I promise
you I would work out more mm-hmm I
promise you these things are true I
promise you I would probably work more
mm-hmm I bet you all of those things are
true because and what do you what do you
think about that it sounds horrible
my god what can't we have fun like over
whatever like but just like I don't know
like what over there friends houses I'm
like tonight is off the record right and
like we talked about like I mean like
like literally off the record like no
foot you can't take a photo you can't
tweet anything tonight because like
we're just gonna talk and have fun and
do whatever and it's off the record like
it's sort of I'm not saying it's Vegas
you know in the microcosm I'm just
saying like like even don't repeat it
like just like let it live like let's
live in this talk is have dinner what
about the asymmetry that Nassim Nicholas
Taleb talks about where your private
life is different than your public life
and that asymmetry is actually unhealthy
because then you're a different person
in those two scenarios well I would
argue the same way that I needed to
write books in a certain voice and then
express a different part of my
personality this is how people actually
become whole is through that dualism I'd
in an ideal world sure you could be
yourself at all times but who goes to
work where they get to be themselves
entirely right I'm almost there
I would say yeah well getting there
that's it's great that I think is people
I think some people people get more or
get more comfortable that's right uh and
they don't feel like they have to do
this self presentation things yeah yeah
[Music]